hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast refinement of a model of
repeated cerebrospinal fluid collection
in conscious rats presented by Eva Maria
Altmann
clinical vet Marian comparative medicine
Basel Roche Pharma research and early
development Roche Innovation Centre
Basel I'm Alexis Kraus of labyrinth and
I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on your screen
well if there's many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the
accreditation button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me in
welcoming dr. Amin I will now turn the
presentation over to her I'm very
honored to be invited for lab Rhodes and
I'm very happy to present our findings
on repeated cerebral spinal fluid
collection in conscious Rath a model
that we refined here at the reservation
center in Basel it's not so first of all
I would like to give you a quick
overview on the content which we're
talking about today
so we first it going over a quick
introduction on cerebral spinal fluid
itself about service bridle fluid
sampling in pre-created player
preclinical research sorry about that
and sampling in rats
here at the Rose Innovation Center in
Belleville we want to look at the
refinement we did for the established
model we have in house a quick overview
on the animal and animals and methods we
used overview of the modifications we
actually implemented the outcome
indicators that we look for finally the
results and the discussion and
conclusions and based on those results
before going over to the acknowledgments
and some key references so just for
first introduction the cerebral spinal
fluid or CSF if they're produced mainly
by the choroid plexus and the open
Diamond layer of the brain centric euler
system so you can see right here it is
here in the coral plexus um it then goes
from the lateral ventricles over the
interventricular foramen ah into the
third ventricle over then via the
cerebral aqueduct into the fourth and
from there into the subarachnoid space
so the movement of the fish with the
fluid of this here that it is in a
single outward direction from the
ventricles but it is Marta directionally
in the subarachnoid space so it is been
a liter drained through the intracranial
and spiral aragonite delight into the
venous blood and it does play a very
important role in the homeostasis of a
central nervous system here's a sampling
in preclinical research is mainly or
many many times used a surrogate measure
of drug concentrations or rather of
their availability in the central
nervous system and since a filtration
studies in animals still remain a
practical option for the assessment of
pns drug delivery in early preclinical
drug development so analysis of CSF or
of cerebrospinal fluid
allows us to study different disease
for instance accumulation of
extracellular inter amyloid plaques
which are characteristic for Alzheimer's
disease or damage of the blood-brain
barrier at the Black Sea or spinal fluid
barrier during multiple sclerosis to
only be able to name a few of them so
just to mention a bit of the challenge
of the blood-brain barrier there we do
have in preclinical research or in total
we have the challenge of really bringing
large molecules into the brain across
the spectrum area because they are
simply too large to pass so the brain
barrier represents an obstacle and
applying for a therapeutic antibodies
into the brain from the dead which we
would need to treat neurological
disorders and to point that only about
0.1% of injected antibodies which would
for instance remove plaques in
Alzheimer's disease are really able to
cause flatter the blood-brain barrier so
we do see a limited effectiveness
however the brain does have natural
mechanisms which engage certain
receptors on the back brain barriers of
on its surface and these allow certain
large molecules
prosit and here across a therapeutic
antibodies were engineered which were
just using these metal receptors on the
blood-brain barrier and they inserted a
module that binds to these natural
receptors and combine them with a
therapeutic antibody and thereby enhance
the therapeutic the uptake of the
therapeutic antibodies into the brain so
we can see up to a 50 fold improvement
in the uptake and in the activity of in
preclinical models so this so-called
brain shadow could so the technology of
this brain turtle could potentially
transport all types of therapeutic
knowledge
into the brain regardless all their
intrinsic ability to cross the
blood-brain barrier by themselves so
also in this regard the study of CNM and
the scent of sampling itself is very
very valuable in preclinical research so
just give you an overview in
experimental setting CSF sampling may be
performed at either with the ventricles
all the system in a manga or Lambos
video sites so if it is in in the sister
namana
it may be with or without skin and
muscle preparation at the total surface
of the neck in this slide for for the
interval of visualizing we have a human
skull and brain so you can see the
cisterna magna right here at the total
part of the neck and in the lower
picture you can see just for a quick
overview the location of the vertebra
and of the of the different lineages
there just be aware that the needle
sticking in this picture is not in the
subarachnoid space but in the epidural
space so if you want to spare to a
sample CSF at that side you would have
to film insert the needle bit further
into the subarachnoid space there are
different in vivo C's as models
available for securing chronic and
either in anesthetized or in conscious
animals in ruff there are a few acute a
few acute CSF sampling models available
which can be by a number powder through
a skin incision it can be by a pointer
of the sternum Akana
so this is what you see in the picture
you see a rascal so the left part of the
picture is where the animals nose would
be then you have to solve a cerebellum
and then you see the cistern Amira and
the sampling site for this father
cerebral spinal fluid from the sternum
Amla there are various walls in
anesthetized orang away crafts available
which can be done with or without
through ataxic fixation of the animals
they normally use either repeated
anesthesia or and with repeated mantra
of the cistern aligner or also sometimes
repeated internal desserts
cisterna manga in awake animals so we
have to be aware that both repeated
anesthesia as well as repeated
contouring of awake animals can be very
distressful for the animals also the
anesthesia could really greatly bias the
experimental results always depending on
your experimental readout and we should
not forget that this will be also highly
highly dependent on the researchers
skills so there are a few challenges
with repeated puncturing are mainly the
manufacture of the cisterna magma is
highly dependent on researcher skill has
already said because the researcher
needs to be able to unambiguously
identify the puncture site and to
control the down of anneal insertion so
you may end up with quite a few animals
that are used during the learning curve
until the researcher has acquired these
tools and also we have to say that by
repeating puncturing we could end up
with a blood vessel or tissue damage and
consequently with CSF contamination with
blood and and we now have seen the
function of the blood-brain barrier it
is quite logical that this could really
lead to falsification of the results
because normally the large molecule
concentration in the blood is quite
higher than in their CSS so if you end
up continent contaminating your CSF with
blood you may end up with falsified
results or even with not usable results
meaning that you have been using animals
and are not able to use the results
created with these animals also normally
quite large numbers of animals will be
necessary if you'd need to various time
points something which is not very
consistent with the idea of three hours
and also you know will have the
challenge of quite high into individual
variability
however there are also Chronicle and
chronic animal models for the CSF
sampling available this must also
involves a surgical implementation of
cannula which can be either in the
lateral lateral ventricles or in the
cisterna Magna and in the system amana
it can be either through the occipital
bone or through the interpreter bone
this cannon is normally allow repeated
sampling of CSF in conscious and freely
moving animals because they can live
quite well once the cannula has healed
in and everything is closed properly the
animals can be used as their own
controls which is quite nice in
longitudinal studies so you will
normally are able to increase animal
welfare and allow and then analysis of
samples without potential bias due to
anesthesia and also one fix cannula can
reduce the risk of contaminating the CSF
samples which was most likely occur if
you had to read to do repeated untrain
of the sister no matter what we did here
at the wrote Innovation Centre in Basel
we had an established model which had
been used for quite a few years and we
had implemented some steps we find the
method so we were to spectively reviewed
it for outcome we're talking about the
chronograph CSS model we are talking
about rats who underwent stereotactic
surgery with implementation implants or
implantation of a cannula in the sister
Romana
the cannula is sterilized onto the skull
using dental cement and after a week of
recovery the CSF can be collected in the
conscious breath and here in house this
model has been used both for the
validation of optimization of the novel
product black brain barrier transporters
so the blood-brain so the the brain
shuttle we have been talking about
earlier and also for the development of
new drugs for the neuroscience our
hypothesis was that by refining the
method so by implementing other
physiological based anesthesia and
analgesia by using state-of-the-art
perioperative monitoring and supportive
care by increasing stability and at
acidity of the cement cannula assembly
and by selecting a more adapted animal
strain we would be able to improve the
outcome of the model which was
quantified by perioperative mortality by
survival time and by stability of the
implant and then thus we would also be
able to greatly enhance animal welfare
the animals and methods were used we're
talking only about mail address and we
used the data of 14 Vista and 339
whisper honk let's just be reminded that
we're talking about a retrospective
study so the timeframe in which these
data were collected was between 2009 and
2014 we did stereotaxic surgery with
implementation of a cannula in the
sister Najma the cannula was stabilized
onto the skull using dental cement and a
series of modifications was implemented
to refine the original procedure here in
the victory you will be able to see um
already the skull of the rats so the rat
is fixed in this
traffic frame you can see just in the
front a nose cone where the animal is
supplied with oxygen you can see that
the surgical field is the draped it is
already prepared you can already see
that the skull has been prepared and
there are anchoring screws in the skull
the end the cannula is right before
being lowered into the cistern Amarna
over on the next slide you can see the
wrapped or right position in this tear
attack so the animal is under anesthesia
you see that the eyes have been covered
with the ion meant to prevent this
occasion of the cornea the animal is
provided with oxygen via the nose mask
and the surgical field has already been
clipped an aseptic prepared and in the
next picture on the right side you see
that already the skull has been prepared
the animal is has been sterile right and
you already see the skull structures for
the orientation on the skull and to see
where the cannula really has to be
inserted and this is a fast forward so
here you see an wrapped after the
surgery where you can see just on top of
the head you see the head cap and made
of cement and the cannula so this is the
cement cannula assembling you will be
able to see a bit of time on cubing
which secures the metal mandra in the
cannula and you see that that the roof
in is sutured around the hair cap just
to give you a few a quick overview of
the modifications which were really
implemented so on the left hand side you
will see the pre refinement on the right
side of the post refinement methods so
in terms of anesthesia and analgesia
through refinement we here
a mixture of a hundred milligrams per
kilogram hit a mine and ten milligrams
per kilogram Dyna sign which was given
by intraperitoneal injection we did use
the low reversal of anesthesia and the
pre-emptive analgesia zero point zero 25
milligram per kilogram poppy larvae were
given subcutaneously and the animals
also received one milligram per kilogram
block succumb subcutaneously after
surgery which was continued for us once
a day for three days as opposed to that
culture environment animals received for
anesthesia and mixture of 0.15 milligram
per kilogram minute a Medina 2 milligram
per Kluber midazolam and 5 micrograms
per kilogram fentanyl which was a bonus
subcutaneously instead of
intraperitoneal ii the anesthesia
waterers we also a mix of the preneur
fin 0.05 milligram per kilogram
automatic diamonds all 0.75 milligram
per kilogram and pure methanol 0.2
milligram per kilogram also administered
subcutaneously and energy here the
animals received first the open orphan
which was was already intervening the
antagonize ation mix and also the 1
milligram per kilogram meloxicam
which have been also administered
subcutaneously after surgery and
continued her us once a day for three
days in terms of perioperative monitor
in care pre environment the animals
where spontaneously breathing room air
and were monitored by a vector
temperature and anesthetic death by
pinch reflex we change that into
spontaneous breathing oxygen via the
nose mask and the animals will monitor
heart rate oxygen saturation of blood
and also the body temperature and
anesthetic depth by toe pinch heart rate
and whiskers movements regarding their
septic technique
pre-retirement we did you surgical
but we did not use the right rating
which was then added in the post
refinement procedure and to to just let
you know the dental cement would be
changed pre refinement we had a two
component cement palador
which was mainly an issue in terms of
occupational health and safety because
it is based on methacrylate copolymers
which emit ecwid fumes and which can be
quite toxic for the personnel so we
change that we also been a few serious
with a glove universe cement called the
GCF ug son and in the post refinement
setting we had a you look yourself you
pure self-adhesive anniversary agent
cement Jason combined with a 40 percent
phosphoric acid etching gel and light
curing bonding agent we looked for
several outcome indicators so mainly we
had perioperative mortality and death
per gram sorry very operative mortality
which was defined as death under
anesthesia and within 24 hours after
surgery we looked for animals to by the
time we find a base of the use of
animals and wrapped with a survival time
between day 1 up to base 64 surgery
we're considered for the statistical
analysis we looked for stability of the
cannula cement assembly which was
defined by base of firm adhesion of the
assembly through the animal skull so
whenever we saw visible instability
which was noticed when manipulating the
animals for checking for CSF flow but
also complete loss of the assembly we're
both defined as loss of some way and
lack of the place we also another
analyzed the for duration of surgery
measured in time in minutes between the
incision of the skin as the finished
suture
and to analyze these educators both
parametric and nonparametric tests were
used so let's get over to the results so
first of all we have the perioperative
mortality just to remind it was defined
as the perioperative mortality the death
under anesthesia and within 24 hours
after surgery and here we can clearly
see a significant significant job so in
the pre refinement setting we had seven
animals out of 73 who died in these 24
hours
compared to four out of 322 you will see
that in the first setting we will have
quite a few whisperers and some
Westerham rats wears in the post
refinement we have only Western hundreds
I will come to that difference in this
strain later next result survival time
called which was just to remind it was
defined as the day of use of animal with
a cuddle of 60 days so an allowance of
between day 1 and day 6 equal surgery
were considered and also here the
survival time significantly increase
with a requirement of the technique so
after refinement we had 36 plus minus 14
days compared to 28 plus minus 18 days
in regards of the stability of the
cement cannula assembly also measured in
days of fermentation we could see a
significantly higher stability of the
cement cannula assembly both compared
and so of the news event of the JCL both
compared to palador and to the glass
remote the future self and in term in
regarding the peridot
also old compared twister and twister
hundreds so there were significant
significantly higher stability compared
to all other groups for the GSM for the
surgery duration however we could see
that the new technique was significantly
longer so this was defined as time in
minutes between the first cut the first
incision and the future and yes the news
event was taken quite longer as compared
to flee to other cements and which we
attributed to that basis due to do some
additional intermediate steps like
several times light curing for the new
cement we have some more results so just
to let you know about the strain
influence I said we are talking about
retrospective analysis of data and we
are including data from both mr. and
with their Han male rats and the reason
for the change of the strain was so
initially the the model was started with
mr. rats but the with the rats have a
rather steep increase in the body weight
which renders them quite large to be
safely handled and to overcome this
problem we selected with the hamlets
which can gain weight at a much slower
pace than the Whizzer bus and we checked
for differences between the strains for
all the indicators we checked so for the
perioperative mortality for the animal
survival time for stability of the
cannula cement assembly for duration of
surgery and for interoperate positivity
and as we did will not see any
significant difference between these two
strains for any of the indicators we
decided to include the data from both
strains to also be able to increase the
statistical value
we had some other considerations so just
like in North free refinement no
attention given another special
attention was given to post-operative
feeding so the animals were provided
with the normal standard rat chow or rat
palates and that's it but after careful
observation of the animals we seen so
the rat seem to have some problems with
knowing and with biting the standard
read show so we presume that they were
experiencing some discomfort at the
surgical site when applying pressure to
their teeth so after reviewing the
technique we also offer them soft gel
after the surgery in addition to the
standard color so that they could
rejoice between the normal parts and the
soft show five to three days the soft
rolls very accepted by the animals
however we did not see any significant
difference in the body weight after one
week of the surgery so it may be then
one week is too late to really see a
difference that we would have have to
check them one or two days after surgery
or maybe the way to development in the
first week of the surgery and so we do
not have a significant difference here
but nevertheless at least by the animal
research and animal caretakers people
still considered a refinement by the
animals caretakers which were they
observing the animals but just it's a
caveat this may be purely subjective
also another point which we changed
while refined procedure is that for the
post-operative recovery phase we always
provide the animals with warmth but
first it was a hidden lamp which has a
more focused and more cultural warmth
and we changed that to forced-air
patient warming so for instance that
they are having
which are the big blankets with warm air
and we seem to have observed that the
animals recovered a bit better and
quicker in this newer setting with the
warm blankets but again we do not have
any data on this so this may be purely
subjective so to come to the discussion
and conclusions after the retrospective
review the in-house performance of our
model was considered quite low and the
process were analyzed and consequently
refined to obtain better outcome and we
could find that the holistic
pathophysiological driven and model
tailored refinement of the methodical
part improve the outcome of the model
and animal welfare by significantly
reducing mortality increasing survival
time and improving the stability of the
cement in cannula assembling what we did
see was the anesthesia one tailors to
pathophysiological modifications in
cerebral autoregulation which is in here
into the model and to avoid further
functional impairment a a mounting model
of mechanism based a balanced energy Xia
targeting all processes were some other
sections for construction transmission
modulation and perception was
implemented we use state-of-the-art
perioperative care including aseptic
techniques to reduce also microbial
contamination of the to the lowest
possible practical level and thereby
reducing morbidity and mortality and
increasing reproducibility of the model
and also we used a new cement type which
was not only superior in terms of
adaptation of Health and medicine and
safety by avoiding the exposure of
exposure of personal to the ecwid field
which might be toxic on also in terms of
ease of handling a facility and a
significantly higher stability of the
cement
cannula sampling
so in the end we consider that overall
the concept of three hours by the Roslyn
birch root successfully address and
animal welfare was improved by reducing
the total number of animals needed
thanks to lower mortality or euthanasia
due to technical failure and increased
usage timeframe of the individual rats
and by improving the scientific quality
of the model I would like to acknowledge
some people
so dr. Alessandro Percodan oh my further
of my formal line manager who really
made this analysis possible and who was
really really helping us a lot in the
interpretation of the data with neuro
break Aizen who together with me really
implemented the refinements dr. Lisa
stark eldest son who helped us with a
statistical analysis with Larissa : oh
did the tedious work of gathering all
and and putting together all the data
from the with respective records and
Miss Veronica Ellison and dr. Edwin who
also performed some of the surgeries so
you will see of course it has not been
just invented by us but we were inspired
by great minds that came before us and
with this I am happy to receive any
questions and I hand over back to Alexis
[Music]
thank you dr. Amin for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left or
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for let's get
started how long do to recover after
surgery before they are used in an
experiment
thank you for the question we do give
the animals one week so they are allowed
to recover for one week before being
able to be placed into any experiment
and in this week they are closely
monitored they are checked daily for
well-being they are checked weekly for
the for the weight development and also
one week after surgery they are checked
folders for the flow of the cerebral
spinal fluid so whether it's working or
not
our next question is do you use the rats
and repeated experiments if so how many
experiments may the animals be used for
thank you this is quite an interesting
question because this is just the beauty
of this of this setup because the
animals are you can use them in a
longitudinal study and they can serve as
their own control so yes you can use
them in a repeated experiments in our
case it's always have to be object with
the Swiss authorities or the controller
authorities and we do have the
permission to the two to use them for
one experiment per week for maximum of
six weeks with one week of recovery
between each experiments and so we can
perform several samplings each sampling
you can calculate about ten microliters
of silde and if for instance you need to
do a pique study you can calculate about
a maximum 7 to 8 something's per day for
one experiment and then you have to give
them one week of recovery after that our
next question is do you keep the rat
single house after the surgery and if so
why family we have to keep them single
housed after the surgery so we tried
also to keep them social health but we
experienced that as the rest
be very playful you have noticed I think
that that we have this little tyke on
cubing on the Mantha which secures the
rival inside the cannula so there is a
quite large risk that a rat will know
when it will play with it so that will
then remove the mother that feels the
cannula and we have quite a high
hydrostatic pressure of the CSF fluid
which is higher than the atmospheric
pressure so an accidental rule of the
manga where the will result in
uncontrolled spilling of a theater and
this will first produce a strong
reduction of the CSF pressure and then
it can ultimately lead to the death of
that so also if you have uncontrolled
opening this will also or can also lead
to infection and contamination which
also will end up with maybe death or
infection or at and endangering the
well-being of the webs okay so we have
time for one more question
why do you think it is advisable to use
a reversible anesthesia protocol um in
an advert in a reserve of wool
thank you sorry I have to repeat in a
reversible anesthesia protocol you can
really allow these allow for targeted on
a seizure time or you have three agents
and each of these agents can be
counteracted so at the end of the
surgery the animals are fully
antagonized except for the energizer
how's the book there is also a beauty of
these of this protocol you have the can
turn on the receptors which are then
displaced by the bookmarking
but still providing the energy so the
animals can recover within minutes they
typically experience a smooth and short
recovery phase and
laughter specially as compared to the
Academy excellence in protocol where the
recovery time is quite long normally
because it relies on retribution and
metabolism and especially in small
mammals it's quite important to keep the
current pace as soon as as short as
possible so because the faster the
animals return to normal physiology the
less morbidity and mortality you will
end up wait I hope this answers your
question perfect I would like to once
again thank dr. Amin for her
presentation I would also like to thank
labyrinth for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May of 2018 you will receive an email
from bobrucz letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share about announcement with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon
goodbye thank you